thierry ardisson qui élit mater qui
invente des interviews et les méchants
vita c'est thierry ardisson est capable
d'expliquer on ne bouge pas pendant le
jingle assez formidable
c'est énorme
[Musique]
bon bah il n'a pas bougé un cil
discipline s laurent ruquier ce fut un
plaisir vous a bien dressés et marc
olivier fogiel jospin qui m'a dit il
faut prôner l'immobilisme ça de ce côté
là il est fort dites moi bon on va faire
une interview à l'envers donc je vous
donne les réponses et vous me donnez les
questions est assez compliqué s'annonce
si vous allez voir si je vous dis par
exemple laurence boccolini alors
j'explique à nous habituer spectateurs
c'est la jeune femme qui a remplacé cinq
grands mouvements faits qualifiés de
remplacer laurent ruquier sur sur france
inter laurence boccolini faut que je
trouve la caisse qui a trouvé la
question qui va qui devait amener à
cette réponse que la fille qui n'aurait
pas dû appeler son émission rien à voir
quand elle a voulu remplacer la main
alors laurence boccolini a été remplacée
récemment par stéphane bern ce qui
prouve bien que laurent ruquier qui
remplaça puisque linda hardy n'y est pas
arrivé non plus alors si je vous dis
stéphane bern ots quelle est la question
fait les questions et les réponses en
jeu moi je fais la réponse je vous dit
stéphane bern quelle est la question qu
est le type qui montre ses dents pour
montrer qu'il a autant de couronnes que
de celles dont type vous aviez dit en
parlant de vous aviez vu en parlant de
stéphane bern
ça s'est appelée rien à cirer maintenant
ça s'appelle tout acier
c'est très bien aussi aussi je vous dis
laurent gerra laurent gerra alors telle
est la question la semu alors quel est
le type à qui vous avez succédé sur
europe 1 et que vous avez aidé je crois
à faire démarrer sur france inter
guillaume durand
quel est le type qui fait beaucoup de
succès à fixer avec ses bouquins mais
pas beaucoup avec ses émissions de télé
bruno gaccio alors bas à qui avez-vous
succédé sur canal+ auprès de marque audi
vous en sortez bien quand vous êtes dans
la succession là c'est vous qui me
l'annoncer pas vous n'êtes pas obligé de
poser de pousser dans la succession se
dire marc olivier fogiel votre grand ami
elle est bien c'est celui qui vous a
remplacé dans mon coeur je le comprends
on se remémore
samy naceri samina s'il calait l'invité
qui va vous succéder
voilà non mais c'est comme ça c'est
surtout parce que là c'est très bien
bien alors je vous donne les réponses
comme vous l'avez dit fait clairement et
puis vous me donnez les questions alors
la réponse les tendances et fabrice
luchini qui est le meilleur acteur
français parce que vient en même temps
avec lui philippe sollers
[ __ ] alors je n'ai jamais lu un livre
de comment il s'appelle déjà
et puis je suis totalement inculte il
avait ensuite qu'elle célèbre écrivain
français a une coupe de merde aussi
subsol elle marche bien donc je donne la
réponse
laurent baffie moi je dirais que c'est
un type formidable
déjà je parlerai des scouts et humains
de la personne ouais puis après tu peut
broder là dessus qui est ce mélange de
2,2 grâce d'humour de talent de
sex-appeal
je sais pas linda hardy qui mériterait
d'avoir des plus grosses
mettez votre machine à ce que je sais ce
que vous non par la suite un travail
d'approché vis là je suis marié j'ai des
enfants binda qui a la main droite qui
part un peu en couilles c'est très bien
on continue c'est très bien guy bedos
qui ne manque pas de toupet qu'on nous
applaudit on rallume la lumière
attention bougez pas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors est ce qu'on peut mais c'est un
petit peu la lumière s'il vous plaît
donc l'interview à l'envers c'est très
très simple je vous donne la réponse et
vous me donnez la question alors
allons-y
je vous donne un nom comme ça voulait
dire la question qui aurait pu nous y
amener arthur fait attention à ce que
vous dites mans alors je vais la faire
gentil qu'elle est l'animateur qui
m'appelle moumoune en ils vous appellent
moumoune way à ce gentil je suis un vrai
nous on peut pas appeler mon psy mais le
surnom je suis donné tellement cochon
que si je dirais et ppda quel animateur
qu'est la même voie qu yves lecoq
ouais chose anne claire qu'ils émettent
l'animatrice qui ne part jamais un week
end
ah oui la gaffe qui est l'animateur qui
a des bras ouais ce qu'on les voit
toujours bien l'homme de l'année l'homme
de l'année non quand même télé c'est le
public à voter tous abattus sur un
rocher qui est l'émetteur question à
rocher maintenant gildas s'essuie tu
trouves toujours un petit boulot à canal
+ tombé là j'arrête bus d'ailleurs je
crois à son nom mireille dumas
l'animatrice dont j'aimerais voir la
permanente
oui laurent bignolas alors lui je les
aime beaucoup et ce alors est ce que
j'aime et laurent bignolas
je crois qu'il chausse du 42 ses toiles
âge c'est tout le monde aime bien
laurent bignolas
faut pas rever quoi c'est simple tu es
ardisson qui est animateur qui invente
des interviews
lui
j'ai un peu bougé mais bon alors je vous
donne la réponse
et vous me donnez la question balladur
avez vous des amis de trente ans très
bien chirac
qu'est-ce qui se rajoutent dissoudre
michèle alliot marie est ce qu'une femme
plus récemment s'imposer à des machos
lionel jospin balladur qui est ce qu'il
ya beaucoup de mal avec une majorité
plurielle qui est en train de devenir
une minorité active suite mauvaise foi
philippe seguin
d'après vous qui pourrait devenir maire
de paris douste-blazy
s'il ne fait pas une apparition à
lourdes il pourrait être candidat à
paris ou au sol aux tiberi ce qui a une
faille en tellement belle qu'elle change
de coiffure sans faire de rapport
santini qui est-ce qui répond à une
interview si stupide depuis cinq minutes
[Musique]
interview à l'envers michaël youn c'est
pas compliqué je fais les réponses et tu
fais les questions première réponse
benayoun quel est le vrai nom de jean
marie le pen
[Applaudissements]
swarm en ce moment un nombre deuxième
réponse à poils à poil comme en été
raffarin
quand tu l'as vu pour la dernière fois
[Applaudissements]
maintenant il faut ce qu'ils valent à
moins d'un mètre quatre-vingt h visite
j'hésite entre deux questions quelle est
la taille de mon sexe mais ça c'est un
peu facile donc j'irai dans du dur du
méchant fastoche
quelle est la taille de mimie mathy
[Applaudissements]
allait se retire allez je la retire et
vous savez que ça c'est légal dans
l'univers de la blague quand vous avez
une blague qui est mauvaise si vous en
rendez compte
avant quand on vous dit c'est pas bon
j'avais le droit de lever la main dire
ça là je la retire donc c'est comme si
je l'avais fait m6 m6 qu'est-ce que vous
michael qu'est ce que vous aimez qu'une
fille vous fasse en premier
[Applaudissements]
numéro un des ventes qu'est-ce que kenza
du loft cela ne sera jamais vous
connaissez qu'elsa non ben moi non plus
personne ne la connaît c'est ça le
malheur c'est ça le drame de la faire
plus standardiste qu'est devenu lionel
jospin oui le cours florent
quel est le contraire de lelong florent
[Applaudissements]
ça va excusez moi
à la maison elle a été construite autour
de 1970 à celle calculée qu'elle a
obtenu la concession qui vend pour la
première fois à une demoiselle
montmirail qui va partir de l'année et 7
de bronze à montmirail avant la maison
robinson
les anglais fraîchement arrivé après la
conquête de l'île alors je dois vous le
dire tirer c'est assez délicat pour moi
dans l'état de stress dans lequel je
suis à quelques jours du début de mon
spectacle je suis pas capable d'assumer
ce genre de sifflet ce genre de
quolibets jeunes ans excusez moi je ne
suis pas capable d'assumer un bide
donc j'ai une doublure bid qui vient
pour prendre les bides à ma place il
s'appelle jean philippe donc ce que je
vous propose c'est que si vous voulez le
sifflet je vais le chercher tout de
suite et il arrive juste pour le bide
jean philippe sol vous allez voir un
comique de situation
jean philippe jean philippe
ouais
à
comique de personnages s'il fait bien ce
que tu racontes innues oui porte voix
donnez moi un mot qui ne soit pas un
porte jarretelles et porte manteau dans
lequel il y ait porte était de 570
circuler qui avait obtenu la concession
qui
[Applaudissements]
hop
allait elle va laisser terminer alors il
y avait aussi portnawak et et portiques
comme le dj philippe portiques et pour
être sûr de ne rien rater de dinars 10
tubes abonnez vous je m'étais 1 pouces
bleus